hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump continues to declare
that the u.s is rounding the turn on the
pandemic
well former vice president joe biden and
health officials warn
things could get worse as winter
approaches health and human services
secretary alex azar discusses
how the federal government is responding
to a nationwide surge in covet 19
infections and the progress made towards
finding a vaccine
with six days until election day there's
been plenty of buzz about
battleground states president trump's
re-election hopes could hinge
on winning north carolina's 15 electoral
votes
the state is also a key player and
democratic lawmakers push
to regain the senate fox news
correspondent mark meredith joins the
rundown
with reporting on recent poll numbers in
the tar heel state
and a nail-biting senate race in south
carolina
plus commentary from fox news
contributor pastor robert jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm bill hemmer i'm janis dean i'm juan
williams and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday october 28 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
new treatments exist and a vaccine is on
the way
but for now cases of covet are surging
hospitalizations are up
and winter is coming you do not need to
shut down to protect public health
wash your hands watch your distance wear
your face covers when you can't watch
your distance
i'm dave anthony it's a state that's not
just
key to who wins the presidential
election but also which party controls
the senate
north carolina you now have a democratic
governor you've got a close senate race
this is what a state you would think
maybe solid red but it's really not this
is certainly a toss-up state
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
one thing is certain no matter who wins
the election november 3rd
we will still be talking about covet 19
for weeks and months to come
especially as we deal with a surge in
cases nationwide now
the cdc says covet 19 circulation and
associated illnesses
have been increasing since september
driven primarily they say by
activity in the southeastern and central
parts of the country
that since the end of september weekly
hospitalization rates have increased
driven mostly by an increase in rates in
adults 50 years and older
saturday saw a new case high total in
the united states
just last friday 83
000 new cases in one day saturday
another 83 000 cases
nearly 1 000 people a day are dying
another 200 000 deaths are expected
over the next several months former vice
president and democratic presidential
nominee joe biden said we will control
the pandemic
contrary to what president trump's chief
of staff said over the weekend
the president said this week after
surviving kovit himself
that we would be worse off if biden had
been in charge during this pandemic
we will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth
a safe vaccine that quickly ends the
pandemic and we're rounding the turn
they hate it when i say it
with or without we have the vaccine it's
going to be great meanwhile two weeks
after dr david navarro with the world
health organization said lockdowns and
shutdowns should be a last resort
that poverty and economic implications
are important to consider
the who's mike ryan said this week after
looking at virus numbers in europe and
the united states
it may require shutting down
and restricting movement and having
stayed home orders
in order to take the heat out of this
phase of the pandemic
as the next phase will be colder
literally
and as more people gather and stay
indoors during winter
the virus may shift yet again well cases
are in fact increasing
especially in the midwest upper midwest
and the plains and upper plains areas
we're seeing uh fairly substantial
increases in numbers of cases
alex azar is the health and human
services secretary but frankly we're
seeing this
really in large parts of the country
right now
these changes are driven really by
individual behaviors
a lot of it is coming out of household
gatherings people just getting together
with family members
extended family neighborhood gatherings
friends
and we're seeing a lot of transmission
that way and that's why we're trying to
emphasize to people
um right now as we move indoors as it
gets colder
please you gotta still practice those
three w's more than ever inside which is
wash your hands
watch your distance wear your face
covering when you can't watch your
distance and stay out of settings where
you can't do those things
we have um roughly 42 000 people
hospitalized that is not the highest
number we've seen
during the pandemic um but the but the
president says despite these numbers
we're turning a corner
it might not feel like that when we look
at these increases but what is
what is your sense well what the
president's talking about is first were
in a dramatically better position today
than we were many months ago you know
and
just from a mortality perspective on
this disease
in april if you were 70 years and above
and you got coveted you had over a 30
percent chance of dying
now that has been reduced by almost 70
percent
in terms of the potential mortality
impact on you
thanks to the therapeutics that the
president's leadership has brought rem
deaf severe steroids convalescent plasma
higher quality care uh adequate
equipment ventilators etc in the system
and then what he's talking about is
because of operation warp speed uh we
are on the cusp
of next generation therapeutics like
these monoclonal antibodies that can
prevent and treat the disease
as well as vaccines just really weeks to
months away from all of that and that
that's the real hope here
but we need people in the interim to
bridge to that by
really good individual behaviors
practicing those three w's that i
mentioned
i want to get more into that but i have
one more question about the the
increasing numbers
because we're hearing from as you said
sort of localized regional areas new
mexico
texas wisconsin and of course utah
um that there are some hospital capacity
issues because of covid
are we talking about maybe having fema
and army corps go back out and and build
those makeshift hospitals like we kind
of did back in
in april so we're here to support them
we're actively engaged through hhs and
fema with
all of our state partners we're talking
directly to hospital systems also
uh and you know right now uh what you
see
is increasing cases that lead to
increasing hospitalizations
and if they get to capacity levels
they'll first work to manage their
capacity of course with elective
procedures that are filling up beds in
their hospitals
but we will be there to support them
we're fielding any requests for health
care personnel
or other types of support that's what
we're here to do to back them up
uh and we've been able to manage that
with the states that we're interacting
with we haven't seen major size requests
at this point but were
were engaged with all of them to provide
the support that they might need
talk to me about what you were just
talking about the
the um the treatments um let's start
with the president's case because
as we all know our president had covet
and he talks about um regeneron's
antibody therapy that he felt like
superman that he you know he even calls
it sort of like a cure for him
can you talk about this therapy a little
bit especially since
my understanding is eli lilly now says
its antibody treatment
does not work on those with advanced
covid
so first let's let's talk a bit about
what these therapies
are so when you get the virus your body
has a natural immune response hopefully
to it which produces antibodies which go
after basically
uh tackling and killing the virus
convalescent plasma which is what we
authorized over the summer
is when is taking those antibodies that
your
somebody's body has produced in recovery
and then giving those to somebody else
monoclonal antibodies the regeneron or
the eli lilly treatment that are being
studied
that's when we actually bio engineer
those antibodies so we can make them in
massive
quantities and also with purity and give
you a very potent dose and so that's
what the president received was a
cocktail
of these monoclonal antibodies from
regeneron
and you get you give that to someone
when the virus is still in an earlier
stage
an outpatient setting uh so that you can
tackle that virus and i think what we
saw
with uh with the lily drug was once
somebody is an advanced disease as you
mentioned in the inpatient setting
uh you already have enough viral
replication that it may be too late for
it to have that type of effect so you've
got to get
people earlier after they've been tested
positive and are vulnerable
and that's that out those outpatient
studies and both lily and regeneron have
publicly
stated that they have filed applications
with the fda to authorize that use for
their products
okay and um the vaccine
i know we have a few contenders that are
sort of at that late stage of trial
right so
i think you you said earlier in this
very interview were
weeks months where where are we with a
vaccine
sure so we have six candidates that
we've invested in or contracted with
four of them are in late stage clinical
trials
two of them are basically fully enrolled
in their
thirty thousand person plus clinical
trials that's moderna
and pfizer and we're just waiting right
now for data to read out from those
two programs in particular uh that is
out of our control the data will will
come
out whenever pre-specified endpoints are
met in those trials whether that's three
days from now or three weeks from now
what we ought to be celebrating is that
would be an unprecedented
speed for getting data on a vaccine for
a novel pathogen literally we're talking
10 to 11 months
after that hit our shores this virus
that we are talking about
bringing vaccines to the american people
nobody nobody thought that was possible
when
back in january but then you have
another uh uphill battle right and that
is convincing people
that something produced that quickly is
safe
well i think it's important to educate
people why was it done
why would how why and how was it done
quickly it wasn't done quickly by
cutting any corners
uh in terms of the programs uh in terms
of safety of individuals
what we did is the president said let's
use the full power of the federal
government its financial resources so a
drug company
would normally stage out their
investments and it would take time as a
result on the development program
we as absorbed all those costs up front
meaning we could move from one stage to
the next within 24 hours in these trials
instead of months and months of delay
and then we also started manufacturing
all six of these vaccines we are
literally making millions of doses of
vaccine as we speak and stockpiling them
which no drug company ever would have
done that's why you don't have a six
month to year delay even after fda
approval to produce the vaccine
so that's what's being done we're not
cutting any corners
in terms of the fda's standards here for
authorizing any vaccine
how close are we to having like a rapid
accurate maybe even at home test like i
imagine
if we had that like or i could maybe
test myself daily before leaving the
house that would
that would be like a major help or is
that just way too idealistic
to want that well we already have
actually delivered
uh the rapid accurate immediate test
those are now fifty percent of the three
million tests that we have per day
available are those rapid point of care
test
now what we don't have yet is a
home-based test um it's important though
to remember
that when you no country no country has
done anything like what we've done in
testing
and no country has a protocol where you
would try to test everybody every day
that's just that's
it's it's neither realistic nor is it an
appropriate use of testing the 330
million americans would test to test
themselves each day
you test for people who are symptomatic
or people who have been around people
who
who have contracted the disease that's
for diagnosis
and then you test for people uh as a
surveillance tool to identify
especially with asymptomatic people uh
outbreaks that may be occurring
under the surface we have that capacity
right now we the president bought 150
million of a rapid paper-based test
um that now we're giving out to the
states
the issue of home testing uh is really a
matter for companies need to show the
data that people could
safely swab themselves without any type
of clinical supervision and
evaluate the test results the technology
is there then becomes just about
human accuracy on doing that and fda
approval
i feel like we've had some conflicting
information from the who um
mike ryan again just this week said we
might have to restrict movements and
even do
shutdowns again um he's looking he said
at virus numbers in europe and
and the united states but just a few
weeks ago a different official with the
who doctor david navarro
said lockdown should be a last resort
and he cited you know tanking economies
and poverty is as crucial to consider
which is it uh i i'm shocked the who is
giving out conflicting public health
information during this crisis
uh you know this is this is the problem
with who's approach
um you know when when when we did travel
restrictions
they attacked our travel restrictions
which helped protect the american people
so that we could
delay and flatten the curve here in the
united states um
when we called on people to wear face
coverings they weren't calling on people
to wear face coverings
it's very clear you do not need to shut
down
you do not need to shut down to protect
public health but you do
need to engage in these basic public
health behaviors if you're in an
impacted community especially
wash your hands watch your distance wear
your face coverings when you can't watch
your distance and stay out of settings
especially these indoor household
gatherings with multi-family or
neighbors
when you're not able to do those
practice those three w's
we have shown with data that we can turn
these outbreaks around we've done in
phoenix and elsewhere
with those simple practices that still
keep us
back to school back to work back to
worship back to health care and
re-engage in our civic
and public life secretary azar thank you
so much for your time
good to be with you thanks for having me
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up one week from today the
election will be over
though who knows if we'll know who won
perhaps
joe biden stop seeing
dignity in one another we've stopped
showing each other respect
too many among us spend more time
shouting and listening
more time fighting than working together
the democratic nominee campaigned in
georgia
have we passed the point of no return
has the heart of this nation turned to
stone
i don't think so i refuse to believe it
the former vice president says he can
bring unity as biden tries to turn a
state that went trump red in 2016
democrat blue
now the president went to three states
he hopes to win again but may not be
able to afford to lose
we're going to win the great state of
michigan
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
the president also rallied in wisconsin
and nebraska
senator kamala harris the democratic vp
nominee went to another battleground
state nevada
which hillary clinton won four years ago
vice president pence
went to another state republicans may
not be able to afford to lose this time
around
north carolina joe biden's running mate
put her
radical environmental agenda ahead of
north carolina
jobs and north carolina agriculture but
i promise you
under president donald trump we will
always put
american workers first the vice
president also went to south carolina on
tuesday sandwiched in between stops in
wilmington and greensboro north carolina
where we caught up with fox news
correspondent mark meredith
it's good to be back out on the trail
you know it's it's just amazing to see
how close we are to the election and to
see these uh in-person events happening
i mean it does remind you
the election is so close after we've
been talking about it and talking about
it
it really is crunch time what is it like
in greensboro
it's the first of the three rallies of
the day for the
vice presidents does he draw a big
enough crowd is it is it like
when the president shows up it's uh
similar in the way that it would look so
it's a very similar backdrop where
you'll see you know the make america
great again banners you'll see a big
american flag
and then they'll have air force two
flight just like air force one would
right up to the
tarmac here in terms of crowd no it's
not going to be nearly as large but i
also think that's by design you know a
trump rally itself
has a as a lot of logistics that go into
this and for a vice president to hold
three rallies in a day you know they got
to be able to staff out as much as they
can
the crowd is out here i mean they're
enthusiastic it's the same music that
you'd hear at a trump event
but i think what's so interesting dave
is that you know north carolina is a
state that trump and pence won
four years ago by it was something like
170 000 votes
right now they are down by about two
percentage points
talk about what can change in four years
time and north carolina itself i mean
you now have a democratic governor
you've got a close senate race
this is what a state you would think
maybe solid red but it's really not this
is certainly a toss-up state
right you talk about two percent are you
talking about what the polls have been
like in the last couple of weeks
i am that's exactly right so we follow
obviously different polling here but i
was just looking at the real clear
politics average which
takes a look at all of the polls that
are coming in and they show again
a biden harris lead but by less than two
points so that really
could be within the margin of error and
and what we're really waiting to find
out
is what will all this early and absentee
ballots uh kind of tell us about where
the race was
already this is amazing 2.6 million
north carolinians have already stopped
in person to vote early uh that is an
incredible number and then you add to
that
800 000 people that have sent their
absentee ballots back in so the ballots
that they got in the mail those returned
i mean that's essentially half of all of
the registered voters in north carolina
they've already decided to vote so
what's interesting when you talk about
these rallies
you know the question has to be how
effective are they because you've
already got half of the state
already voted so that's why you've seen
the campaign continue to hold these over
the last several weeks
whereas maybe you're seeing the biden
harris ticket doing these rallies
closer to the election day it'll be very
interesting to see once the final
results are cast
what kind of impact that early voting
has had yeah it is interesting because
there's been a lot of
record early voting in different states
across the country and i was just
looking
and there was a an analysis on real
clear politics that said in north
carolina
in 2016 early voting democrats had a 10
percent advantage
over uh republicans uh rather 13 percent
advantage over republicans in 2016.
currently it's 10 percent so
four years ago democrats had a bigger
early voting lead in that state than
they do
now and of course the president and and
the vice president won that year so who
knows what it's going to be like
and we've also seen a major shift in the
number of people deciding to go for
non-preference voting or undis
uh independent so obviously you know the
numbers can only tell us you know some
of the story we
north carolina is a swing state and you
know you talk to people here on the
ground
they seem fairly divided you know the
state has still has
very strong uh covet 19 restrictions in
place compared to other places in the
south you know you go across the border
south carolina it feels like a
completely different place than where we
are in north carolina
i've been in raleigh i've been in
charlotte and here in greensboro things
remain
uh fairly strict when it comes to covet
restrictions
you know the vice president also taking
a trip to south carolina
in one of his three stops of the day is
that for
really senator lindsey graham more than
it is for the trump pence ticket
you think i would have to think so i
mean you i can't imagine a situation
where uh the trump pin sticker would
end up losing south carolina a former
resident of that state
uh i mean that is is pretty much solid
red as they come
now in terms of what you're talking
about that specific senate race with
lindsey graham
there are a lot of people questioning
whether or not he'll be able to pull
this through
i know obviously he has been in the
headlines with the confirmation of judge
amy coney barrett as the judiciary chair
but now this is a chance for the
republicans to put all their efforts and
a lot of money
into making sure that he keeps his
senate seat um
in terms of south carolina though i
would imagine that trump and pence will
have no problem keeping the state this
time around
right but being from south carolina are
you surprised that senator graham is in
such a tough election fight
uh you know the one thing with 2020 is
it's hard to get surprised by anything
at this point i mean lindsey graham
has certainly made a name for himself as
one of trump's biggest supporters
and i feel like this is also a state
that is i mean you do look there have
districts that have swung in south
carolina i think of
charleston and what's happened since the
28 midterms
so i mean it's certainly possible that a
congressional seat could flip
i would just be you know really
surprised if a presidential
flip would happen in south carolina but
obviously also
trump and pence they put a lot of time
and energy into the carolinas
overhaul democrats put an even bigger
bullseye on senator lindsey graham
when he led the way for republicans to
get justice amy coney barrett onto the
supreme court
as head of the judiciary committee it's
moments like this
that make everything you go through
matter
it's moments like this where you can
tell young conservative women
there's a place at the table for you
this is a groundbreaking historic moment
democrats say senator graham broke his
word when he told them in 2018 he would
not support
filling a supreme court vacancy in an
election year
graham counters it was the way democrats
treated justice brett kavanaugh that
changed his mind
his challenger is jamie harrison who put
a big focus
on health care as democrats fear
obamacare could be undone
by the supreme court many of our
hospitals and some of our rural
communities are closing right now
what are we going to do to tackle these
disparities
in health care that women and
particularly minority women are
experiencing right
now senator graham has failed in his 25
years to properly address these issues
that was jamie harrison in a debate with
senator graham on wis october 3rd polls
have varied as to who leads this race
in north carolina democrats have another
target in their quest
to win full control of congress senator
tom tillis who's just recovered from the
coronavirus
this is a person who time and time again
shifts his positions writes and rewrites
his record
in order to meet what the special
interests need that's tillis challenger
cal cunningham during a recent debate
now the democrat has been dealing with
the fallout of romantic
texts that leaked uncovering an
extra-marital affair
cunningham apologized for senator tillis
told
fox i honestly think that the only
honorable thing cal cunningham could do
right now
is to withdraw from the race reconcile
with his family
and rebuild his reputation but
cunningham hasn't just stayed in the
race he's ahead
in quite a few polls back to mark
meredith
yes that's been the case uh pretty much
all along here where tillis has kind of
been in the fight of his political life
right now uh the average that i've seen
is that cunningham's up by about the
same that biden harris are in this state
by about two percentage points but this
race has tightened
just in october alone it's amazing to
see how close it's gotten i want to say
before tillis was down by six points at
the beginning of the month
and now they're essentially down two so
i mean you'd have to say it
it's an even pace here tom tillis is
somebody that uh
you know obviously north carolinians are
always thankful to have
a uh you know majority in the senate but
if the senate is going to flip this
would be a chance for cunningham
to uh to be able to sell that majority
here so this is not only a presidential
contest
but as you mentioned a very very
important senate race
cal cunningham has had to deal with a
little bit of a scandal of his own with
an extramarital affair
and obviously that is uh possible that
it could weigh on voters minds
but you have to think too about who's
coming out for cunningham right now this
is likely not about a personal issue
but how they feel about the current
administration and about the balance of
power in the senate as opposed to the
candidate itself
himself yeah and and in
north carolina where have you seen a lot
of signs around do you see a lot of
biden signs a lot of trump signs have
you noticed anything does it look
like it typically does i see a lot of tv
ads a lot of radio ads this morning
in terms of signage nothing that would
just you know blow you away compared to
other states like iowa or new hampshire
before a contest
it just doesn't have that feel i was in
north carolina when the rnc was supposed
to happen
remember it was supposed to be in
charlotte then it was moved to
jacksonville and then it was moved back
to washington
and i'll tell you what that was
something that was surreal to me because
this was an
area for the republicans to really show
we are going to put every resource we
have in north carolina really try to
sell the state
and then it didn't happen the convention
that i saw that one day that it happened
down here
was almost a joke i mean it was one or
two signs outside the convention center
there was not a big turnout they had a
lot of security but
you would never have known there was a
convention here and i also am really
curious how many businesses are really
upset with the way that they kind of got
uh
shafted by not being able to get that uh
revenue back into the city of charlotte
and of course all throughout north
carolina
well it's certainly gonna be interesting
those 15 electoral votes are very much
up for grabs and either side they want
them badly
mark meredith fox news correspondent in
greensboro thanks very much for joining
us
thanks for having me
it's the perino and styrowalt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris steyerwald
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind every time an
election rolls around our national
conversation reaches
a fever pitch politics are all anyone
can talk about
people argue endlessly about this policy
and about that candidate
and then about half of them stay home on
election day
and don't vote you may feel fed up with
politics
you may be ready to wash your hands of
the whole dirty business
but that's not how god's people are told
to act in the political sphere
in scripture as a christian and as an
american
it's not only your right to vote it's
your responsibility
in the old testament when the people of
judah were hauled off into exile
in babylon by king nebuchadnezzar the
prophet jeremiah wrote them a letter
you might think he would have told them
alright everyone here's the plan
whatever you do be sure to keep yourself
out of babylonian politics
hide in a holy huddle wait for god to
smite those pagans and then
hurry on back home to jerusalem but
that's not what jeremiah said
he delivered this message from god in
jeremiah 29 verse 7.
seek the welfare of the city where i
have sent you into exile
and pray to the lord on its behalf for
in its welfare you will find your
welfare
god was under no illusions that babylon
was a perfect place
it was a decadent and wicked city yet
god told his people not to withdraw he
told them
to engage they didn't know how long they
would be there
they knew they were ultimately citizens
of god's heavenly city
and yet they were told to dig in and get
to work
on behalf of babylon they were supposed
to pray
and work to make their earthly city just
a little bit better
than how they had found it this didn't
mean compromising on their convictions
or throwing out their bibles but it
meant doing what they could do to help
make things better
jesus taught us the same thing when he
was asked to name the greatest
commandment in the law
he refused to name just one he named two
you shall love the lord your god with
all your heart and with all of your soul
and with all of your mind and a second
is like it
you shall love your neighbor as yourself
we're not supposed to have a
relationship with
god while neglecting or ignoring the
needs of our neighbors
we're called to work for their good that
means we
have to care about politics because
politics is where we haggle
over how best to seek out the common
good
in our country in particular we have a
participatory democracy
as john jay the first chief justice of
the supreme court said
god has given us the privilege of
choosing our leaders
in this christian nation so it's our job
to vote for the candidate
and the party whose policies will best
contribute to
the moral and spiritual good of our
neighbors
or we should at least vote for the party
who will hurt the common good
the least politics in a sinful world
will always be messy and imperfect
every nation will resemble babylon a lot
more than it will resemble
the new jerusalem but that's no excuse
for disengaging from politics
out of disgust or despair sitting it out
is no option at all
for the love of god and neighbor get out
there and
vote then pray to the lord on behalf of
our nation
and trust him with the results this is
robert
jeffress with fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with bret bear with updates
from reporters on the trail and
in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race go to
foxnewspodcast.com and download the
campaign with bret baer now
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes